Tijuana la ciudad fronteriza con Estados
Unidos empezó el año manchada por sangre
con seis días de diferencia fueron
asesinados dos periodistas Margarito
Martínez y Lourdes Maldonado dos casos
que representan los múltiples peligros a
los que se enfrentan los reporteros
mexicanos en 2019 Lourdes Maldonado
acudió al presidente de México para
pedirle ayuda a sentirse amenazada por
un senador del partido en el poder
vengo también aquí para pedirle apoyo
ayuda y Justicia laboral porque hasta
temo por mi vida se trata de un
personaje fuerte en política se trata de
su senador con licencia y su candidato
próximo candidato a la gubernatura de
Baja California licenciado Jaime Bonilla
Lourdes fue asesinada a tiros frente a
su casa el 23 de enero mientras que ella
consideraba que La amenaza provenía del
mundo político su colega Margarito
Martínez se le temía el crimen
organizado se dedicó a cubrir los
asesinatos que ocurren diariamente en
las calles de Tijuana él también fue
ultimado a tiros frente a su casa la
investigación en curso apunta al líder
de un grupo criminal local como autor
intelectual
no va a haber impunidad ni en el asunto
de Margarito ni el asunto de Lourdes hay
algunos autores materiales también Ya
bajo proceso y también tenemos en la
mira ya próxima a autores intelectuales
mientras que la impunidad y los ataques
contra la prensa suele ser casi total
México sigue siendo país más mortífero
del mundo para los periodistas muy por
delante de países en guerra como Ucrania
esto representa más que un tercio de los
reporteros asesinados en el mundo este
año sin embargo el presidente mexicano
desacredita constantemente a la prensa
sigue sin ser así el comportamiento de
los medios que actúan no en
representación de los ciudadanos sino
que actúan en función de intereses
atrapados en el fuego cruzado entre el
mundo político y el crimen organizado
que a veces van de la mano los gritos de
auxilio de los periodistas no parecen
ser escuchados 2022 es el año más
mortífero registrado para la profesión
en México